hey guys and welcome back to City
skylines today will be all about the
details
in and around the new city and that'll
be brilliance and windbreakers but also
these smaller details the playgrounds
and the center of the town and I really
want to make it feel much more alive
than just the way it's laid out at the
moment and to be perfectly honest this
is probably my favorite episode so far
and really one of my favorites of the
entire series you'll see a lot of three
lines that they don't f initely
and first and foremost I wanted to get
to the industrial area and also add some
tree lines to that I actually find that
especially in these newer industrial
areas where there's mixed-use so a lot
of these offices as well I really wanted
to make sure that it would be quite
decorated and the best way to go about
doing that was by ending these trees to
make it feel a little bit less dead it's
probably something that I should also
return to in the future
since I don't think this is something
that I've said yet but since no for
updates I can't use the pedestrian roads
anymore and they've all turned into
gravel roads so all of the places where
I use pedestrian roads to get things
done I will sort of revamp in the future
with new textures but more or less
things will be finished in this episode
and really most of the decorations I
wanted to get in here were quite simple
and tree line decorations I didn't feel
quite the need to add extra assets to it
just randomly spawned character cargo or
containers since it already felt like
there's enough assets as it is with all
the buildings and I didn't want to quite
make things look too messy that's
something I'll definitely get to when I
get to the harbour but I really wanted
to get a more clean outer industrial /
retail zone look to this area which
means a lot of three lines amongst other
things as well the hardest point was
actually to try and get this to look
right since really and this is one of my
issues I have with the game the zoning
spaces are quite limited and buildings
don't get larger than four by four when
it comes to zone buildings and
especially in these type of retail areas
you would find really large building
bill
with enormous footprints especially when
it comes to large retailers or
distribution centers and that's
something that you can't really Zone in
which is why most of these areas will
actually be monuments or unique
buildings which is partly a problem
because they don't actually function as
industrial areas I just wanted to make
them look like they are convincingly
industrial areas but they actually
aren't so while that means I won't have
to mess with the annoying traffic issues
I still get a pretty bad industrial
demand and also some of these buildings
don't have the actual functions that
they look like they should have like one
of the buildings in this industrial area
is a large crematorium which makes no
sense so the idea is that no it's it's
more of a type of industrial building
but really had to be creative in a way
with getting these other larger
footprint buildings to look like an
industrial area another building is
actually a recycling center and there's
probably a couple of retail stores in
there as well but yeah that's something
which I just wanted to do to get
buildings with a large footprints in
there to make it to look like an
industrial area since buildings in such
spaces have really large footprints
though again around that I wanted to
scatter some smaller buildings and some
offices as well so didn't want to zone
some offices but aside from that it's
pretty much just unique buildings there
and I did this thing with the crop
fields again and something which I
should mention about it is that
realistically I should have some soil
underneath these things so may may want
to get back to that in the future and
actually pick up some soil assets with
which like come with soil and crops at
the same time which I know we're out
there somewhere I don't know why I
pointed it over here but then again I
also kind of like the freedom of placing
the crops yourself but the crops fields
are still something I should return to
in the future same goes actually for
these greenhouses I try to get some
greenhouses in there since and this is
something which I really didn't have yet
in the city you see many greenhouses in
the Netherlands and actually some areas
in the Netherlands where most of the
agriculture is in greenhouses so you
really have the
enormous fast fields of just glass
greenhouses everywhere and you know I
wanted to get a few greenhouses in there
but the issue with this really is that
these don't come as unique buildings so
they are farms
and what I can just I drop them to
certain places in the end it didn't work
since all of the greenhouses also needed
Goods and workers and there was no way I
could sustain this huge amount of farms
and the need for transport and workers
to actually work so yeah that experiment
with the greenhouses just failed in the
end and I can't believe the greenhouses
but hopefully at some point in future I
can and find a way to make them unique
buildings I try to but then the asset
editor for me just completely doesn't
work think it's compare Oh
incompatible with one of the mods which
I have and I thought it was some roads
but apparently it turned out to be not
some roads and now I have no clue how to
kill you get the SML etre to work but
yeah it's something I might want to
return to but no in the near future try
to get the greenhouses in but at the
moment it just doesn't work now the rest
of this area is really just filled in in
I have a typical way which I also
described in last episode where I try to
get some curvy roads and small dead
rivers in and then try to create some
long strokes between that old farm
fields also wanted to have a couple of
football fields in this little area and
generally it's like 1 football field per
couple thousand people in the
Netherlands if you look at talent sizes
compared to how many fields they have I
really felt that compared to the town
size of this town I might want to get
away 3 football fields it's not that
much but it should be alright and also
wanted to get a small horse thing I
haven't done it I don't know the English
word for it but basically this places
these places where horses are I guess
where people have their horses and write
them I should look that up and a tennis
court as well just a small Sports
Complex but nothing big really since
it's such a small town and figured if
people are gonna go and do some very
unorthodox sports like be part of an
athletics club and there is still the
other town which is quite close by
but yeah that no you saw the issue with
the greenhouses there was no way I could
keep them up so actually for some time I
still tried to place and replace them
but that there was no way that would
work since they disappear way too
quickly I mean only way I think in which
I could fix the transport issue is by
making a highway connection really close
to the greenhouses here but aside from
the fact that that would make no sense
to have to highway connections or exits
that close to each other in a rural
neighborhood it also just wouldn't work
since I really want to keep all of the
traffic to the town on that national
highway Road since it just has a much
larger capacity than this little road on
top of the Dyke here so yeah that's the
general way in which I want to make this
earlier most of this area is gonna look
pretty much the same as the fields that
I have over here albeit that there are a
couple of things which I do add to it in
the future like a highway resting area
in which you have some gas stations
aside the highway and also a McDonald's
in another restaurants and just some
places where trucks can stop for a bit
and have a rest
some pretty sure they're legally
supposed to do so and also another
highway exits but the next highway exit
I want to add is gonna be quite far away
from the town which I have at the moment
so the National Railroad I mean the
National Highway which is currently
clogging up this roundabout over here
it's still gonna be the only way to get
into the town then I have at the moment
and while it's really busy and there's a
lot of traffic I really just want to
keep it like this and I really don't
want to make it more efficient and have
a larger capacity just for the sake of
trying to get the traffic to work
because realistically you wouldn't see a
very large highway or Road go to such a
small town as I have over here and here
I really just wanted to have a lot of
three lines three lines are gonna be
like one of the most common things
you'll see me place probably near future
one of the reasons I wanted to do so is
not just because you see them quite
often in the Netherlands I also think
they do look really nice but they're
also sort of necessary in a sense that
the Netherlands is an extremely flat
country like you won't
and a country that is flatter than the
Netherlands probably and so there's a
lot of wind and you don't have wind if
you're trying to grow crops so at least
the trees sort of help alleviate this
there are definitely other ways in which
you can stop the wind but that's a bit
ridiculous and aside from their
functional while their functionality as
a windbreaker of course I think three
lines just really nice and you see them
quite a lot in the Netherlands and
especially when you have one of these
more barren areas around roads it's just
nice to have these three lines to make
it look a little bit more alive in
general really trees make something some
areas look really live even if they are
completely filled with concrete so
that's really is something which I want
to use them for as well and you
especially see them sort of around the
main roads in an area where you have
three lines on both sides of the road so
that's why I wanted to have it over here
but something to note about this area is
that at the moment the town doesn't have
any ditches or any body of water and
that is something which I do want to get
back to in the future as well so when it
comes to that main sort of entrance Road
next to this roundabouts I do an added
ditch alongside it in the future and
I'll see what other water I can add
around this town in the future but it's
something which I'm not quite doing
quite yet and over here I wanted to
decorate this area a lot since it is
supposedly in a way kind of like the
centre of the city it's not the historic
centre but really the more recent
addition with some of the necessities
that were sort of necessary as the town
growth grew larger so there's these
supermarkets actually there's two
supermarkets over here and a high school
as well since I think if this town was
just about large enough to have a high
school and just about far enough from
the high schools in the large city that
I wanted to have a separate one over
here so this is sort of like the main
center of the city in a functionalist
way might want to add a City Hall to
this little area in the future and but
yeah this area is also very much a
little shared space area which is why I
also wanted to put the bricks over the
over here and have a pedestrian road
underneath it just to make sure that not
too much traffic would use that area but
you can still use it to get to the other
side of the town but it's also
pedestrian friendly at the same time and
shared space roads also sort of allow
you to place more planters and have more
decorations on the roads which given how
much of the center of the city it is I
really felt would be quite a good
addition to that area and also wanted to
actually use the bricks over here as I
added these playgrounds and decorate
this a bit though I will have to say
this is unrealistically overly decorated
by far definitely since I added two
playgrounds over here which is quite
ridiculous even for the Dutch standards
so I'm I'm going to switch it up a
little bit like gets get like the seesaw
on one side of that little dual
playground and like some swings on the
other side and at least make sure that
they have different playground things
because right now they're just twice the
same playground and very close proximity
to each other which is kind of weird and
then I had to place the hatches of
course I really wanted to do this since
without it it just doesn't look as
realistic especially when you look at it
from the air the only thing that I'm
really missing in these gardens and this
is quite a crucial thing which I'm
missing but I don't think I'll get back
to because it's quite time-consuming but
I might in the future is that at the
back of like the gardens houses usually
have a small shed where you can plug
your bikes and have some other stuff
that you might need but don't want to
put in your house like I I know some
people actually put that fryer in there
or like other machinery and you very
commonly see them in nearly all Dutch
houses at the end of the backyard
there's always this small shed and
that's something which I don't have at
all so far and it's something which I
might want to add in the future so yeah
it is something which I realize I sort
of don't have so far but I'm not really
sure if I want to do it
since it might just look awkward and by
the time I want to get back to it I'm
gonna have to place hundreds of sheds in
succession I'm not quite sure how much I
would look forward to doing that not to
mention that these hatches are mostly
placed to sort of carve out in different
backyards but they're not entirely meant
to make 100% realistic backyards since
that's just the level of detail which
though it would be nice to go into would
just be too time-consuming and I'd
rather actually move on and also be able
to look at the larger aspect so I'm
trying because I'm trying to make a very
large touch region in this case but I
also want to go into detail and it's
hard to do those two things at the same
time so you sort of want to compensate
for now having to place too many details
like sheds and at least keep some focus
on the general area and yeah really the
backyards from the from an aerial
perspective still the convincingly
shapes I believe and it's mostly there
so that you can sort of see this shape
develop as you would realistically see
it this is by the way also I think a
really good example of how much more
alive trees make an area view and it's
really important especially when you
just compare how this area looks without
trees and comparing with how it looks
with trees it makes a huge difference
and you can probably make a pretty
poorly designed neighborhood look quite
all right as long as you add enough
foliage to it just something to think
about
I've probably talked about this before
but you know this is also why artists
when they make a render of a pretty bad
building like to put many trees in front
of them because then you don't see how
bad the building is anymore like
architects always like to put all sorts
of trees on the balconies and roof tops
of buildings but it really isn't going
to happen in real life and here we see a
ridiculously overly themed and decorated
splay ground I think I kind of went
overboard we've done as well might want
to keep it a bit more simple and this is
really I feel one of the more
convincingly Dutch cauliflower
neighborhoods which of other subjects
and this is entirely the reason why I
want to get back to the cauliflower
neighborhood perhaps in the future that
still have it in the old town because I
said at some points that I wanted to
maybe remove that cauliflower
neighborhood and which I built and I
think it was episode 4 and actually got
met with a lot of no you shouldn't do
that but I still feel like I might at
some point in the future if I ever find
the time to because at the moment I just
don't feel and has quite the level of
detail which I'm putting in these
neighborhoods I think this is so far my
favorite parts of the entire map and
definitely getting better all the time
when it comes to making these
neighborhoods though there is still of
things that I'm missing but the point is
that at the time that I was making the
old cauliflower type neighborhood in the
large city I didn't quite put as many as
much detail and experience into it as I
did for these houses so now I feel like
even though it's not entirely that bad
there's a huge level of difference in
the quality of the neighborhood so
that's the main reason why I might want
to redo it in the future not because I
don't have a cauliflower neighborhood
anymore I'll definitely keep that idea
but because I just feel like there is
too much of a yeah like a difference
between them which could almost break
you out of your immersion and speaking
of buildings which don't entirely have
the purpose which they supposedly have
this is a crematorium over here but I
really figured it wouldn't be nice to
have it as a crematorium so this might
actually be the City Hall I could call
it that's I guess it sort of looks like
a City Hall ish building I really feel
like it's too fancy to actually be a
crematorium and obviously I was planning
to have a small graveyard over here in
the middle of the town but really felt
like it would be better to decorate it a
little bit add some benches and also a
small football park since otherwise
there wouldn't quite be enough leisure
time in the city and if I ever want to
get to it I may well add a graveyard
more outside with the city but the
moments it doesn't actually have such a
thing so that's also something to think
about anyway that is almost about it for
this episode but I still have a small
flying camera thing at the end of it and
that should show off what the town looks
like in a little bit more
follower bore if that is even a word way
than the time-lapse shots but yeah the
town isn't entirely finished so that's
something to keep in mind there are some
smaller details that I'll still want to
get into in the future and to make sure
buildings I want to add and the other
side of the railroad isn't even finished
yet but this is how the general area is
looking at the moments and I definitely
still need to add a sculpture or
something in the middle of that
roundabouts you don't commonly see
around them outer with nothing in the
middle of it realistically I'd love to
see I'd love to be able to put some
signposts in the middle of it pointing
to what directions lead to where as you
would commonly see but that's something
I can't really do learned how the
roundabouts at the bottom right over
there is sort of just a filler may well
get back to that currently spelled Muse
because I was like couldn't really come
up with anything into place in there so
I just placed whatever I was listening
to at the moment and yeah this is
basically how the area looks and is a
bit more closed shorts actually did add
a couple more bicycles and smaller
details around here as since it just
isn't a Dutch City without random
bicycles thrown about just about
everywhere and part against every wall
that is available and this is really a
type of 60s 70s hobbitses neighborhood
nothing too interesting but I think it
was quite a lot of fun to make it and
the city center like this is the old
center so it has the church and a more
random layouts but it's not the old city
centre in the sense that it's where you
go to shop and where most of the city
life is happening this is sort of the
old part so while it's the most
picturesque probably it isn't the most
alive and like the newer part which is
this over here is more or less supposed
to be more of the modern centre of the
town but yeah that's about it for this
episode so thank you guys for watching a
quite quite a lot of cars actually still
using that shared space place I also
probably overuse the flowers and the
roundabouts yeah but whatever anyway
goodbye